he's traveled far and wide and enjoys
great recognition abroad
but in her home country she can barely
move about and has to hide away koshen
iboga sara is fighting for the rights of
gays and lesbians in uganda but in
britain so many times i can't count how
many times I've been beaten people have
come out openly on social media and
saying if they get hold of me I went to
cut off my head they're going to put
tracks on on my body and all this so I
have to really really always watch my
back she can barely leave her house but
for her the threat has a positive side
no one can deny anymore that there are
gays and lesbians in Uganda I live here
with my partner and my cousin brother
and his button so it's a gay house no oh
we have so many people who are living
together secretly some pretend to be
best friends and others pretend to be
actually married so yes we have actually
you in the pink village of Uganda
they're said to be half a million gays
and lesbians in the country they're
probably more her rights organization
wants to use bombastic Uganda's only
LGBT magazine to educate people it's
aimed mainly at non gays and they hold
an annual parade as well this year's in
August was the fourth there's a great
deal of help from abroad supporters of
the movement donate money to the
magazine but back home they constantly
face hostility from the media just the
people they need as advocates pelting
stones to us these are the people who
are pointing fingers these are people
who are sexually abusing us who are
beating us so we need them to report
positives that we can minimize these
risks in 2014 the government wanted to
pass a law that would put gays and
lesbians behind bars for life after
protests by activists and international
pressure
it was overturned
among the people on the streets
ignorance and fear prevail
I reject homosexuality if a man sleeps
with you you ruin yourself the gays want
to sleep with you you can earn money
people can choose for themselves they
don't want to be homosexual they don't
have to be Casanova casseras feelings of
guilt bother her more than rejection
because of her sexuality her mother died
of a heart attack
many say because she feared for her
daughter's safety I almost lost my life
after the loss of my mother I abused
alcohol I went into depression and then
I said would she be happy to see me like
this
I just woke up one day put the alcohol
down but medicine they gave put it aside
and said I'm not sick I'm just being
stupid
my mom stood everything left right and
center people people you threw words
that her for protecting me for standing
with me and she stood it would she'll be
happy to see me today drowning picked up
my bones and said back to the fight more
and more people in the country are
following suit even though they're
frightened of newer harsher laws in the
future I'm really really hopeful for the
movement in Uganda because even when
others go at as commendable and but so
there is hope there is no doubt there is
hope and the movement is strong the
movement exists and the challenges are
there but we also register some
successes that kept us going the
alternative Nobel Prize might give cash
an abacus or some protection in the
future and strengthen her in her fight
for LGBT rights